parce qu'ils sont maintenant ils sont
vivants
ce qui s'est passé
je chéris ou escoudé ton frère
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec lui
puisque tu sais au moins
[Musique]
je pardonnerai jamais à louis
balises
tout est parti d'un mauvais pied
gauche puisque c'est celui sur le christ
club depuis sa naissance
je devrai capitaux depuis ma naissance
rappel le 10 ans commente contre la
peine avait pris toute la place main sur
un homme salue plus depuis des années en
termes un croisement la rue elle
s'enfuit avec horreur je tends jouer
tous les soirs
vous pouvez pas prendre des médicaments
comme ça c'est beaucoup trop pourquoi
avez vous senti que les quoi de moi de
ce que j'endure
et c'est un génie rien jour le génie
c'était toi et ça tu as 10
[Musique]
lui sa notoriété grandit cgt déchiré
e
pourquoi vous n'avez jamais cherché à
réparer crypte rue courbet la grande
soeur elle était sa haine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pardon
[Musique]